teheran 4 millions d'habitants capitale
d'un pays gros producteur de pétrole et
où l'essence coûte presque moins cher
que l'eau se fait une région comme tant
d'autres pendant vingt-cinq siècles on
l'appelait la perse puis en deux règnes
seulement c'est devenu une grande nation
est désormais une grande puissance
l'iran les immeubles surgissent de terre
les drapeaux un peu partout cris la
fierté nationale
l'argent tiré du pétrole ont dit les
pétrodollars permet au delà de
l'industrialisation la mise sur pied et
l'équipement d'une prêteur tarn et nous
le verrons plus loin ce ne sont pas
seulement des régiments de parable c'est
une arme et ultramoderne super équipe
est un élément primordial du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
un seul mètre en iran le chat l'époux de
farah pahlavi exhibe à l'achat banni ils
ont quatre enfants l'aîné des fils c'est
le prince héritier le chat pour parler
un instant comme le protocole sa majesté
impériale mohammed reza pahlavi
c'est son nom chaim charia mais c'est à
dire la lumière les aryens 57 ans et
déjà 35 ans de règne sauf l'empereur du
japon il y a de par le monde
aucun chef d'état qui exerçait ses
fonctions depuis si longtemps le shine
ch devant lui en public en iran chacun
marque sa différence
qu'y at-il derrière à 15 minutes du
centre de la capitale le palais de
niavaran ce n'est pas un château au sens
où nous l'entendons plutôt une très
belle demeure sobre de ligne c'est ici
que vit la famille impériale jusqu'en
avril
ici on est à 15 cents mètres d'altitude
500 m 2 se terrant la ville même et on
n'est pas très loin des montagnes où la
famille impériale va faire du ski qui
est le chat in châ quelles sont ses
qualités ses défauts
notre but est de le demander à lui-même
et naturellement aussi à l'achat mais
nous fera dans la bibliothèque de qui
nous pénétrons d'abord qu'elle est notre
première rencontre beaucoup de légendes
courent où là dessus avez vous été
présenté au souverain à paris à terrain
à 83,6 était présentée au roi par et
quand je faisais des études
parmi les étudiants iraniens qui lui
avaient été présentées mais il ne se
souvient pas bien sûr de ce moment et
après je lui était présentée à terra je
pensais bien que c'était l'été 59e lui
étaient présentés chez sa fille la
princesse fiona peut-on vous demandez
s'il vous a plu dès le premier regard
s'il m'a plu c'est à dire j'ai toujours
beaucoup d'admiration
et d'amour et de respect pour le roi est
la chose qui m'a touché c'était ça son
contact sa façon de parler qui était
très simple et très naturelle parce
qu'il est normal que quand on est en
dehors
ne parlez surtout enfin chez nous quand
on est jeune on pense que les rois vivre
différemment les rênes parle autrement
mais de voir cette simplicité qu'il est
comme tout le monde cela m'a beaucoup
impressionné donc elles sont des
qualités qui vous plaisent maintenant
chez votre cou après tant d'années de
mariage
je pense qu'en tant que rennes peut être
dans ma position ce qui peut c'est
difficile de partager les deux mais
plutôt en tant que reine
le roi était toujours quelqu'un qui m'a
toujours donné confiance qui a été
vraiment comme une montagne solide
derrière moi pendant toutes ses 17 ans
il y a eu des moments d'inquiétude et
dieu sait combien des moments difficiles
il a eu mais il ne me l'ait ne les a
jamais fait sentir
il a toujours été comme ça il est
d'ailleurs comme ça pour son peuple
parce qu'il est normal que coton sans
son chef inquiet au est troublée ça ça
trouble davantage le peuple son
entourage est ce que pour vous vos
sujets sont vos fils vos frères vos
compagnons d'armes
ou bien sont ils vont croiser mais
croisés en croire un temps de croiser à
d'éventuels oui sinon c'est ce sont mes
fils mes enfants mes frères mes
compagnons
je m'occupe te je vis pour eux
et jusqu'à présent ils ont fait la même
chose pour moi le bonheur de votre
peuple l'idée essentielle de notre rêve
oui le bonheur mais je l'entends le
bonheur dans l'honneur je peux me
référer au terme de père de deux chefs
de famille celui qu'on écoute parce qu'
il est plus âgé
sinon d'âge mais au moins d'expérience
et tialata bien qu' il n'y a pas de
doute
ceci s'est accompagnée de mes fonctions
et des prérogatives constitutionnelles
est acquise par 35 années de règne qui
n'est pas quand même négligeable ce
leroy qui qui est là depuis 35 ans et
qui a passé par des périodes assez
variés quelques fois extraordinaire et
voilà le tour fait de moi ce que je suis
on dit sa majesté impériale
vous vous dites le roi alors faut-il
dire l'ampleur le roi enfin la preuve je
ne pense pas que ce soit l'exacte
traduction du cha cha le roi des rois et
le roi des rois peut-être mais ce n'est
pas exactement non plus leur honneur
avez vous des amis malheureusement pas
et je crois d'ailleurs que ce serait
très difficile d'avoir un dans ma
position à cause de l'opposition c'est à
cause de votre personne
je dirais automatiquement à cause de ma
position mais si je pense un peu elle
bien alors je commencerai à avoir des
doutes aussi et pourquoi ne peut-on pas
être prêt d'ici rillettes être les gens
qui n'ont n'attendent rien de vous
auquel vous pouvez rien donné qu'ils ne
peuvent rien demandé et qui peuvent vous
aimez vous même mais sont très nombreux
seulement je ne le connais pas ce sont
les gens de la rue la rue ici et les
grouillante de monde un peuple toujours
affairé en des affaires qui paraissait
aller bien il y a quinze ans on a
promulgué des célèbres révolution du
chat et du peuple
on a édicté les 17 points de cette
grande charte du bien-être social de la
justice sociale de la culture populaire
de la redistribution des terres on s'y
réfère constamment dans chaque discours
de quelque importance
la foire est très vive et fait excellent
ménage avec la vie moderne dans ce pays
où le souverain se dit un mystique
l'un des points essentiels de la
révolution c'est la participation des
travailleurs aux bénéfices pour le shine
schaaf
que signifie la participation de chacun
et pour son pays et peuvent même une
raison d'être
une raison de vouloir à la vivre et
continuer alors nous allons vers la
pourra dire la participation à outrance
parce que j'aimerais que nos
cultivateurs nos paysans possède des
actions du sinn
on va faciliter cette chose langue de
bureaux derrière sa table et bien lui
aussi der posséder des actions par
exemple dans l'industrie du pays
c'est peut être ainsi que nous non plus
d'un différend dans ces pays un
agriculteur ne resterez pas indifférent
à ceux ci l'industrie marche bien on pas
il serait plutôt intéressé à ce qu'il
marche bien on voit partout quand on se
promène à terrain et dans les autres
villes bien m'ont pas plu aussi on voit
partout vous photographier celle de la
famille impériale
est-ce que c'est simplement un symbole
ou est ce que c'est une marque d'amour
pour votre personne ce que je peux dire
avec certitude c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
obligés de faire ceux qui vous aiment
disent que vous êtes avenant drôle
généreuse spirituel et puis et d'autres
personnes disposaient c'est vers autun
orgueilleux voire cruel qu'est ce qui
est exact votre habilité ce qui ne l'est
pas
cruel je ne pense pas autant sur
certainement
orgueilleux peut-être un peu mais pour
mon pays pour ce qui a déçu je ne peux
pas devenir regagné personnellement
puisque je suis un croyant je crois
fermement en dieu et je suis un mystique
alors comment ce que je pourrais être
rendues devant l'éternel on n'est rien
on est absolument rien n'existe pas mais
devant deux réalisations qui ont été
faites dans ce pays il ya quoi de l'être
un peu quand même
sûrement mais cruel mais c'est pas moi
que tous ces organisations de l'état qui
doivent c'est leur devoir de chercher
qui veut nuit à ce pays et de les
neutraliser
si on appelle ça de la cruauté et bien
nous aurons une différence d'opinion
cruel je peux dire absolument pas il
n'est pas au top c'est parfois par sa
position
son contact il peut le paraître
mais il ne l'est pas du tout il est il
est simple danse avait pris mais
vraiment c'est son travail sur son
peuple qu'elle peut importe plus
important pour lui le reste devient
important vous êtes à personne au monde
qui le connaît le mieux qu'elle avait
t-il c'est quelqu'un qui sait écouter
malgré ce qu'on peut penser parfois cela
dépend comment on lui présente la chose
si on présente la chose en tant que
naître adulte responsable
il écoute et il peut vraiment acceptée
vous avez discuté avec je le sens je
retourne sur moi comme expérience
s'il ya une chose que je vais lui
présenter si je prend un air grognon ou
comme une personne qui parle sans savoir
lire lt la responsabilité la réaction
est différente que si je peux parler
calmement
intelligemment autant que adultes et
responsables même comment est-il avec
ses enfants et ils burent pour tendre il
est très tendre avec les enfants est
très ouvert la relation entre le roi et
les en france c'est vraiment ce n'est
pas ça ne peut pas être comparée à sa
relation avec entre lui et son père par
exemple
bien sûr nous vivons dans d'autres temps
il est en même temps c'est vers il ya
des moments où quand il dit qu'il faut
que quelque chose se fasse il faut que
cela se fasse et des enfants ne discute
pas avec moi il discute davantage ce
vendredi-là salam salut public au chat
c'était l'anniversaire du jour lointain
où le prophète désigna ali son cousin
comme saint patron de la perse le chat
un chat est accueilli par monsieur rêver
d'un premier ministre un lieu parisien
d'ailleurs qu'il il adresse au souverain
noté le geste du bras de celui ci et
baise la main le chat un chat va
maintenant recevoir l'hommage du
gouvernement des corps constitués des
dignitaires
c'est une longue série m
les habits sombres des à paris tout le
monde ou presque dans l'ancienne
génération parle un français parfait
le chat est maintenant suivie par le
premier ministre monsieur reid ap et par
le ministre de la cour monsieur
il n'y a pas que l'existence public
naturellement il ya aussi la vie privée
mais à téhéran a en tout cas le couple
impérial ne peut pas lui donner trop de
place l'emploi du temps ne le permet pas
et le souverain nous confirme que les
déjeuner en tête à tête par exemple et
sauf exception sont pour lui et pour son
épouse très court trop court
les prenez vous en général pour pas en
compagnie de la baie d'hudson toujours
mais on pas les enfants très rarement
avec des enfants peut-être des
journaleux congé là quand ils n'ont pas
le cas parce que les enfants - jeux à
l'école avec leurs amis leurs camarades
vous est il souvent dans la journée
suffisamment souvent à votre gré et à
son deuil oui bien sûr on aimerait avoir
plus de temps libre ensemble ce qui est
possible
heureusement pendant les vacances mais
pendant les jours de travail je le vois
le matin nous déjeunons toujours en
tête-à-tête
sauf s'il ya des invités et les soirs
une grande partie au tête-à-tête et
parfois en famille entre les amis et
j'ai surtout l'occasion de lui parler
pendant ces temps là ce n'est pas le
meilleur moment de parler travail
pendant le déjeuner ou dîner ou après le
dîner
après le dîner quand sa journée de
travail fini par abandonner le travail
cesse le sien et votre de quoi parlez
vous je dois dire que c'est très
difficile d'encore deux séparé le
travail et la vie privée parce que c'est
devenu tellement mélanger mes genoux
parlant du travail parce que moi j'ai
besoin à ce moment là de lui poser
certaines questions et nous parlons de
tous de nous mêmes des enfants de le
problème des amis du monde du pays de
tous quels sont vos bas saint cyr ont
dit vous êtes un minable le joueur de
caen
côté impôts canon le bris du très
longtemps que je peux jouer au croquet
de quelques fois et peut-être cette peau
elle amusée certains français si je
parlais que je joue à la belote un blog
et vous aimez sortir enfin c'est un
passe-temps me dit tout de même pas dire
que vous jouer à la belote
l'examinatrice est si la belote ces mois
compliqués on n'a pas besoin d'être
concentré et des fois quand le roi
jouzou pour ce jour dix minutes un quart
d'heure
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
chapin et la valse de l'adieu la
shahbanou est davantage architectes que
musicienne et elle n'entend pas nous
donner le change
[Musique]
je remercie vivement otages étaient
encore une fois ou deux comme viendras
voire deux ans dort c'est la cas famille
chacun avec ses premiers sous s'achète
une voiture n'importe quelle voiture
or les conducteurs de téhéran sont
mauvais ils prennent trop de risques
en tout cas le problème des transports
est devenu pour le couple impérial qui
ne s'en cache pas l'une de ses
préoccupations majeures de son côté
positif que de négatif le côté positif
c'est que ça prouve qu'un pays se
développe
la femme iranienne peut se permet
d'acheter une voiture d'abord ça montre
niveau de vie de la population aussi la
production industrielle du pays
ça c'est le bon côté mais le finir et
côté renault c'est la pollution et ce
trafic incroyable qui lie à téhéran est
depuis des années
nous essayons d'y remédier mais ça ne
s'arrange pas parce que peut-être les
règlements ne sont pas ceux qu'il
fallait que l'iranienne et pas tellement
disciplinés mais vraiment c'est une
chose terrible
le maire de terrain fait tout son
possible pour arriver à améliorer cette
situation et j'espère qu'il réussira sa
part est une des choses les plus
difficiles dans nos pays va je me
demande comment ce que les nerfs de loge
entière doit bien perdre deux heures de
leur temps par jour pour faire un trajet
ou bien même ceux qui ont envie de se
promener un petit peu eh bien on essaie
tous les ponts aériens le pont pour
piétons les rues à sens unique et
bientôt j'espère le métro que nous
faisons avec la collaboration des
français notamment temps révolu et roux
ici pas optimiste dans trois ans il
rendra le premier tron sentiment
fonctionner dans cinq ans ce sera déjà
plus solide mais au fond un métro ça se
termine presque jamais on augmente pour
une grande ville et surtout sur notre
tendu le métro il faut penser entre 120
et 150 km f déjà plus mis trop de votre
vie oui que rarement bleus métro juillet
seulement pris à part et quand
cette étudiante épines ou deux fois
après parce que j'avais la nostalgie du
métro je vais essayer de le prendre
après mon mariage messieurs si vous
passiez dans une rue non pas en iran
mais en europe
est-ce que les gens vous retenez très
oui je pense que oui et qu'est ce que ça
vous fait s'ils ne le connaissaient pas
où je serais content parce que en
sortant de son pays on essaie d un peu
le trouvais l'incognito mais plusieurs
fois n'y est arrivé en france en suisse
même promenaient rue d'entrer dans un
magasin et plus voilà les gens vous
délaissez ah oui il est ridicule de
loterie à longueur de l'auto pays où les
gens sont d'habitude gens qui les gens
sont beaux front d'habitude
et c'est ce que j'ai trouvé vraiment
partout en france en suisse en allemagne
on parle pas des organisations qui sont
faites pour agiter alors ça c'est autre
chose
j'ai eu mal ans et même des jeux pourris
à berlin pourquoi mais c'était une
organisation qui existe encore et qui
continue à faire de la propagande contre
ken l'organisation dans ce pays les
serviteurs du pouvoir dispose de toutes
les facilités voiture de grosse
cylindrée pour enquête ultrarapide
immeubles équipés de tous les moyens de
détection
pour flairé le danger possible en fait
il y à une opposition peut être des
oppositions pour le souverain le danger
principal porte un nom mais rappelons
nous qu'il a été victime d'un attentat
politique il ya 20 ans il n'a échappé à
la mort que par miracle est aussitôt
après il me le parti communiste
hors la loi fils d'un ancien colonel de
casaque
homme à poigne et à cheval sur les
principes le chat inchad aujourd'hui ne
se présente pas comme un libéral
et quelle est votre opinion de la
démocratie à l'occidentale
aujourd'hui ce que nous voyons quelques
fois c'est la dictature d'une petite
minorité
au nom de la démocratie dans beaucoup de
pays c'est les cas ce sont qui font le
plus de bruit ou qui menace de ruiner
complètement l'économie d'un pays qui
ont le dernier mot
moi je n'appellerais pas cela comme
démocratie que faites vous de ceux qui
protestent voulaient m'aider
hors d'état de nuire à votre politique
non ce sont seulement les les
communistes comme est hors d'état de
nuire les autres c'est pratiquement un
portant le nom mais pas tellement
nombreux dans notre pays vous avez est
selon les chiffres que l'on donne dans
votre entourage
actuellement en prison quelque 3000
personnes
pourquoi santé en prison en dehors des
voleurs et des condamnés de droit commun
chez nous le communisme n'est pas légal
il a été mis hors la loi
alors on n'a pas d'autre moyen que de
les mettre 6 hors la loi si le j'ai
entendu sur vous un jeu de mots le chat
bidon à une volonté de faire un
tempérament d'acier elle rit mais tous
les autres en pot tous les autres
sont pas tellement l'on veut pourquoi
des organisations comme amnesty
international
distel que vos prisons sont pleines
police des rapines 58 le lendemain cap
amis etc
si seulement je pouvais dire tout ce que
je savais ça me rendrait les choses très
faciles mais nous avons de très bonnes
raisons de croire que la mission
internationale fait de l'agitation
contre mon pays accepteriez-vous cirque
une délégation par exemple de la
croix-rouge et qu'une délégation du
croissant rouge pour les pays musulmans
viennent de voir dans vos prisons alors
je le ferai tout de suite dit si ça ne
viendrait pas une espèce de précédents
de quel droit est ce que d'autres
personnes viendraient visiter ce qui se
passe dans un pays indépendant
mais quand même je crois que nous avons
fait un nid à un monsieur anglais de
venir filmer notre pays et ont dû a
ouvert toutes les portes
nos prisons est justement montrant des
têtes des personnes que dans la presse
certaines presses internationales
on avait déclaré mort torturé ils sont
là et se portent haut sur moi aussi bien
que vous et moi
cette monnaie reblles en chant versées
et le monument édifié pour le
cinquantenaire de la dynastie des
pahlavi que l'on vient de fêter
solennellement son fondateur reza shah
le premier des pahlavi déjà cités et
père du souverain actuel d'or dans ce
mausolée que construisit l'architecte
fort ou guy marie d'une française
c'est un pèlerinage l'équivalent en iran
de notre tombeau sous l'arc de triomphe
chaque visiteur officielle va fleurir
cet édifice devenus le haut-lieu de la
légende des pahlavi
le deuxième pas la vie c'est le chêne
chat actuelle et pour bien marquer les
choses
de nombreuses rues des villes iraniennes
rappel par leur appellation la maison
régnante
mais depuis quelques temps voici qu'on
voit de plus en plus souvent le
troisième des pahlavi le prince héritier
à 16 ans il est déjà un personnage
considérable se déplaçant dans son
hélicoptère effectuant des voyages
officiels comme récemment en urss ou
comme ici allant recevoir un autre
illustre suivi sur le tapis rouge comme
ceux gharib grand maréchal de la cour en
fait ce jeune garçon va bientôt renier
lui-même son père va abdiquer il l'a dit
lui même dans un livre tout juste sortie
à paris et qu'il a signée de son nom ce
livre s'appelle le lion et le soleil
c'est une suite d'entretiens avec
olivier verrey c'est pour être
absolument sûre vers la succession que
la succession se passe une façon la pure
la plus facile que possible si je reste
encore en vie je pourrais supervisé à
user de mon prestige
là où il le faudrait pour cette
transition et pour que le nouveau roi se
consolidant sa position
c'est uniquement pour cela
est ce que vous ne pensez pas par
exemple didier une chance que les idées
de notre fils dans beaucoup de domaines
soit différent très différentes des
vôtres qui soit plus modeste cette fois
ci nous interrompons cire mais quand
vous dites qu'ils soient plus à l'aise
c'est possible ce que ça signifie que
vous même vous n'êtes pas je ne suis pas
en fonction de mes trente cinq années de
règne tout ce qui s'est passé
la résistance passive contre les
occupants pendant la guerre de retour de
l'azerbaïdjan la révolution de 1953
qu'on a appelé le roi
ensuite la révolution du roi et du
peuple veut tout il est là et formé plus
de 17 points même si on ne veut pas ça
vous créez une auréole que lui n'aurait
pas mais c'est l'âge et l'expérience qui
conduit à prendre
il vous remplace déjà dans un certain
nombre de questions oui oui les grognes
un peu manga qui commence pour
accueillir le fils du roi de thaïlande
le prince iranien et la fable suivait
dans un instant son geste du bras pour
saluer un ministre qui descente d'avion
exactement de style de son père le
château planeur
voilà cela dit j'essaye parfois
d'imaginer un monde sans musique
militaire mais je n'ai pas encore vu
deux régions où l'on sache s'en passer
[Musique]
il
en fait ce futur souverain de l'iran
comment le bois ses parents pour
lesquels ils représentent aujourd'hui
l'espoir
je pense que le prince héritier est un
garçon qui sait prendre des décisions il
a un sens de la responsabilité
la l'exactitude de son père il est
humain et affectueux et je pense que
c'est un bon commencement j'espère qu'il
va s'améliorer au rang 10 ans il est
piloté comme son père il aime conduire
rapidement de voitures et des petits
bateaux comme son père il aime la chasse
comme son père il aime le sport comme
son père et ce cycle est toujours un
père de voir un fils qui ya les intérêts
que lui dans ce domaine mais au point de
vue caractère il justement pour prendre
des décisions prendre des
responsabilités savoir ce qu'il veut est
arrivé à l'avoir et il est beaucoup
comme son père j'ai l'impression même
que vous êtes prêt cire de votre fils je
pense que grâce à dieu c'est un garçon
qui est bien et je sais que c'est
difficile pour lui vous savez il est
difficile d'élever un enfant dans un
milieu qui n'est pas 100% normal et
naturel et il a prouvé dans différentes
occasions qu'il peut être naître
responsable
ce n'est jamais terminé il faut toujours
essayer de se perfectionner mais je suis
content du oui si une valeur voulait que
dieu enlève le cherche à l'affection des
siens qu'il disparaisse avant les 12 ou
15 années qui s'est fixé comme terme
pensez vous que le prince ait départ
vous un homme sera déjà en mesure de les
nier
le roi a fait son testament politique il
a réuni les gens qu'il fallait pour
expliquer et soumettre son testament ce
qu'il veut que iran soir
que nous soyons après s'il n'est pas
envie je pense nous ne serons pas seul
parce qu'il y aura la participation de
notre peuple qui j'ai confiance en notre
peuple c'est une chose qu'on ne peut pas
entreprendre seuil
il faut vraiment la force de tout le
monde et une chaleur les du bon dieu
revenons à aujourd'hui
l'empereur en titre ici à cheval vient
célébrer la journée anniversaire du
retour à l'iran de la province de
l'azerbaïdjan
il y avait fait un moment sécession en
faveur de l'urss
notons que le charmante admirablement de
la cheval pour un homme de 57 ans et qui
n'a guère l'occasion de pratiquer
l'équitation
il
sir quand on voit une carte du monde par
exemple de tokyo jusqu'à lisbonne
on a l'impression que vous voulez que
l'iran comment dire soit une sorte de
vire où je crois que au tombé juste sur
le mois évidemment ça dépend comment on
interprète la question quel monde
quel ordre quelle philosophie et quelle
civilisation
mais si on parle de notre monde soit
disant libre non communiste week ces
deux termes est-ce que les armements
même si vous en diversifier la source
est-ce que les armements considérables
et qui viennent en iran ont quelque
chose à voir avec cette notion de
verrous ah ben c'est sûr
sinon ce n'est pas une plaisanterie ou
bien ouvrir un magasin d'articles de
consommation
c'est pour nous mais naturellement que
nous le faisons mais bien que ce que
nous faisons pour nous mêmes correspond
aujourd'hui aux intérêts le second que
nous venons de parler vous êtes amateurs
d'histoire vous connaissez bien entendu
l'histoire de france à quel roi de
france
pourriez vous comparez c'est très
difficile parce que les grands rois de
france étaient des gens qui faisaient
la plupart du temps la guerre parce que
la guerre était de la mode à ce moment
là ici je n'ai fait la guerre que pour
retrouver l'intégrité de mon pays
heureusement que nous n'avons pas être
attaqué par l'entreprise alors oui la
guerre naturellement mais nous n'allons
pas faire nous la guerre à d'autres
personnes parce que nous n'avons aucune
idée de l'expansion territoriale
y at il dans votre région du monde
1ce de guerre il ya toujours des risques
guerre
csu aujourd'hui un peu moins qu'il ya
quelques années parce qu'on voit de part
et d'autre
des élans vers la paix
[Musique]
mais tant que le mot ne sera pas
tranquille
[Musique]
il ya toujours des risques et c'est pour
cela que nous nous sommes venus arriver
à cette conclusion que tant que le mot
ne s'est pas vraiment pas désarmé mais
tant que le monde n'aurait pas vraiment
accepté que elle vient personne n'impose
sa volonté ou bien ces conceptions
politiques à quelqu'un d'autre part
force ou par subversion il faut toujours
avoir dans l'esprit que un jour
peut-être on devrait faire le sacrifice
national de défendre son pull de toute
manière est inconcevable que il est une
attaque contre l'iran sans que l'iran se
défendre de toutes ses forces à mme
chassot hors de question parce que
qu'est ce qui est arrivé au pays qui se
sont rendus dans la honte sans honneur
sans rien qu'est ce qu'il en est resté
il ya une définition du bonheur est la
suivante c'est de réaliser dans son âge
mûr les rêves de sa jeunesse et 12 un
homme heureux
je pourrais le dire presque
nous parlons ici de de la grande
civilisation
je pourrais me déclarer donc heureux
vraiment lorsque nous entrerons dans
cette gayonne la réalisation évidemment
ce serait quelque chose de ces
éblouissant mais même lorsque nous
atteindrons le sait de la grande
civilisation je pourrais me déclarer un
hangar et s'il y avait dans l'histoire
un surnom pour vous aussi
quel est l'objectif que vous choisiriez
quelle adjectif dont vous aimeriez de
l'histoire le choisit pour vous je crois
que c'est étrange que je laisse cette
prérogative justement à l'histoire
c'était un des juges et des choisi
[Musique]